♪
>> Jesse: ANOTHER FOX NEWS
ALERT.
BREAKING IN WASHINGTON TONIGHT
WHERE OUR CAPITOL HILL
CORRESPONDENT CHAD PERGRAM TELLS
US HE HAS BEEN HEARING WHISPERS
SUGGESTING THERE COULD BE SOME
NEW HIGH PROFILE CONFIRMATION
HEARINGS ON THE HORIZON IN THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES.
WHY IS THIS A BIG DEAL?
BECAUSE THE HOUSE DOES NOT
CONFIRM NORMAL NOMINEES BUT IT
DOES CONFIRM VICE PRESIDENTIAL
NOMINEES.
DOES THIS HAVE SOMETHING TO DO
WITH KAMALA HARRIS?
IT'S NO SECRET SHE HAS BEEN
RUNNING OUT OF FAVOR WITH THE
BIDEN TEAM.
OVER THE WEEKEND SOMEONE AT THE
WHITE HOUSE LEAKED SEVERAL
STORIES CRITICIZING KAMALA FOR
HER CONSTANT GAFFES AND AWKWARD
LAUGHS.
THE VICE PRESIDENT'S OFFICE
RESPONDED TO THOSE LEAKS BY
LEAKING A STORY OF ITS OWN
CALLING THE BIDEN TEAM RACIST.
CHAD PERGRAM JOINS ME NOW.
CHAD, SO WHAT EXACTLY ARE YOU
HEARING?
>> GOOD EVENING, JESSE, THERE IS
A LOT OF CONJECTURE RIGHT NOW
ABOUT THE FUTURE OF VICE
PRESIDENT HARRIS AND LAGGING
POLL NUMBERS.
THIS HAPPENED AT THE WHITE HOUSE
YESTERDAY DURING THE CEREMONY TO
SIGN THE INFRASTRUCTURE BILL.
>> PLEASE WELCOME HEATHER
CURTAINBACH.
>> IN A MOMENT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> THE FAUX PAS WAS PROBABLY NOT
INTENTIONAL BUT IT UNDERSCORED
ISSUES SOME HAVE IN THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION WITH HARRIS.
NOW HERE IS A WINDOW INTO MY
WORLD.
AS YOU KNOW I APPRECIATE
CONGRESSIONAL PROCESS AND
MECHANICS.
SO I GOT A MESSAGE RECENTLY FROM
SOMEONE WHO KNOWS CAPITOL HILL
VERY WELL AND THEY SUGGESTED I
SHOULD FAMILIARIZE MYSELF WITH
THE PROCESS TO CONFIRM A VACANCY
FOR THE VICE PRESIDENT IN THE
SENATE AND IN THE HOUSE.
TO BE CLEAR, TO BE CLEAR, THIS
IS NOT SOMETHING TO SAY THAT
SOMETHING IS AFOOT HERE BUT I
ALWAYS DO MY HOMEWORK ESPECIALLY
ABOUT PROCESS, VICE PRESIDENT
NELSON ROCKEFELLER WHO SERVED
UNDER PRESIDENT FORD WAS THE
LAST VICE PRESIDENT CONFIRMED BY
CONGRESS, THE SENATE AND HOUSE
MUST CONFIRM A VICE PRESIDENT.
JESSE?
>> Jesse: VERY INTERESTING.
WE WILL DEFINITELY STAY ON TOP
OF THAT.
THAT COULD BE BIG NEWS IF IT'S
HEADED IN THAT